bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre l'audition de
marisol touraine ministre de la santé
elle est entendue cet après midi par le
groupe de travail du sénat sur la
présence médicale sur le territoire
français mi décembre la ministre a
présenté un pacte territoire santé pour
réussir là où ses prédécesseurs ont
échoué depuis dix ans il faut dire que
malgré les nombreux plans pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux en france
eh bien la france continue de perdre des
médecins notamment en zone rurale
alors la ministre envisage de créer
notamment des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires dans lesquelles les
jeunes médecins pourrait travailler en
groupe tout de suite donc l'audition de
marisol touraine un bon après midi à
tous alors c'est une audition qui était
très attendu vous pouvez l'imaginer et
qui revêt une très grande importance
pour nous madame la ministre
en effet nous sommes je crois une amie
mon scène de cette commission a
considéré que la question de la présence
médicale sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire est un sujet de préoccupation
majeure de nos concitoyens et
les élus locaux qui administre les
territoires et que nous représentons au
sénat sont évidemment hennetier et
attendre les décisions de la part du
gouvernement pour évidemment essayer de
juguler cette désertification médicale
alors pour éclairer le sénat notre
commission a mis en place dès sa
création au printemps dernier d'ailleurs
un groupe de travail sur le sujet il est
présidé ce groupe par monsieur jean luc
fichet et il a comme rapporteur monsieur
hervé maurey alors plusieurs de nos
collègues ont été effectués avec
plusieurs nos collègues ils ont effectué
de nombreuses auditions des déplacements
je crois quelques déplacements et il
devrait nous présenter prochainement
donc le résultat de ce travail des
conclusions sous quinzaine je pense
puisqu'on a reporté un petit peu le la
présentation de ce dossier
ouais donc en vous souhaitant la
bienvenue je vais tout de suite vous
donner la parole et puis si nous pouvons
je crois prévoir environ 1h 1h30
peut-être c'est à peu près le temps 1h
1h30
bon alors c'est parfait
donc peut-être que les questions sont
nombreuses et que représentation c'est
peut-être le sait pas merci maman oui
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
merci de m'accueillir dans le cadre de
votre groupe de travail je crois que
c'est un moment des changes important et
comme vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
président
la question que l'on appelle maintenant
des déserts médicaux est une question
qui préoccupe beaucoup nos concitoyens
et donc préoccupe légitimement les élus
les élus locaux les élus nationaux et de
ce point de vue là il est important de
pouvoir apporter des réponses
comme vous l'avez vous même souligné je
crois que le plus intéressant résidera
sans doute dans les changes que nous
allons pouvoir engager et donc je vais
vous indiquer de façon assez rapide
les perspectives dans lesquelles le
gouvernement a commencé à travailler et
puis nous instaurerons donc le dialogue
que vous souhaiterez le la priorité pour
le gouvernement et qui au fond irrigue
l'action que je mène c'est de lutter
contre les inégalités sociales et
territoriales
contrairement à une idée reçue canton
regard de l'enjeu des déserts médicaux
on s'aperçoit que le problème n'est pas
un problème de nombre de professionnels
de santé et en particulier de nombre de
médecins même si vous me permettrez de
faire une petite parenthèse à à ce
moment qui est que nous parlons de
déserts médicaux et évidemment nous
devons approché le problème de façon
globale et réfléchir non seulement à la
présence des médecins mais aussi à
celles des professionnels de santé de
façon plus générale
même s'il n'y a pas de mot facile à
utiliser pour cela je ferme la
parenthèse donc parfois même moi je
dirais médecin mais en réalité il faut
parler plus globalement sur ce point
néanmoins je veux évoquer le nombre de
médecins puisque nous en avons deux cent
mille en france aujourd'hui c'est un
nombre très élevé historiquement élevé
et il n'empêche que nous sommes
confrontés à l'absence de professionnels
dans
nombre croissant de nos territoires
puisque on estime à environ 50% de nos
concitoyens qui connaissent des
difficultés d'accès prix globalement ce
peut-être soit le médecin généraliste de
proximité soit des médecins spécialistes
dans certaines spécialités et on pense
en particulier aux ophtalmologistes au
gynécologue et de façon un peu moins
forte mais au pédiatre un peu moins fort
tout simplement parce qu'il ya monde va
évidemment pas avoir un pédiatre
ces inégalités se sont aggravées au
cours des dernières années puisque dans
près de 80 départements on constate une
baisse des effectifs des médecins
généralistes et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne pouvons pas laisser la
situation se dégrader davantage
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
spontanément nous avons tendance lorsque
nous parlons de déserts médicaux a
évoqué des territoires ruraux
mais je veux évidemment insisté sur le
fait que les territoires urbains ne sont
pas à l'abri de ce phénomène banlieue ou
quartiers en difficulté sensible mais y
compris très grande ville et certains
quartiers très grandes villes puisque
nous sommes à paris l'est parisien est
confronté à des difficultés en la
matière que ne connaît pas l'ouest
parisien
alors je voudrais avant de vous
présenter très rapidement les 12
engagements que j'ai que j'ai mise en
avant dans le cadre du pacte territoire
santé que j'ai annoncé au mois de
décembre dernier
je voudrais avant de vous présenter ces
12 engagements faire un point préalable
dont je ne doute pas qu'il donnera lieu
à des discussions en ce 8 mai vous dire
pourquoi je n'ai pas retenu le principe
de la coercition comme modalités de
l'action à engager en la matière au delà
des principes qui peuvent nous animer
les uns ou les autres je voudrais
insister je crois que la liberté des
patients la liberté d'installation sont
des principes anciens dans
dans notre système est au fond moi je
voudrais insister sur le fait que d'une
part la coercition apparaîtrait comme
injuste pour les jeunes générations si
nous devions l'appliquer aujourd'hui aux
jeunes médecins qui vont exercer dans un
an deux ans ou très peu de temps ils
auraient le sentiment de porter eux la
responsabilité des dysfonctionnements
d'un système antérieur et donc font
valoir que trouvent ils trouvent il
trouverait cela injuste et donc
vient ensuite l'idée que n'est pas pour
maintenant que l'on va le mettre en
place mais pour les prochaines
générations c'est dire que les médecins
qui commencerait tout juste leurs études
mais on voit que même si ce point là
pourraient éventuellement faire l'objet
de discussions dans quelques temps
aujourd'hui c'est maintenant que nous
avons besoin de répondre au sujet
puisque la démographie médicale comme
vous le savez elle est en train de
baisser
nous allons atteindre un creux très bas
en 2016
et puis ça va progressivement remonter
donc la situation nous sommes dans la
période la plus difficile en quelque
sorte de prendre aujourd'hui des mesures
qui ne s'applique roi qui ne
s'appliquerait qu'en 2020 2021 et 2022
ne répond pas aux problèmes des français
et des territoires
aujourd'hui donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas retenu cette
démarche nous avons al'inverse
considérer qu'il n'y a pas de mesure
miracle il n'y a pas la mesure à partir
de laquelle on peut dire eh bien voilà
si on la met en oeuvre
nous allons pouvoir lutter efficacement
contre les déserts médicaux nous avons
besoin de jouer sur tout un ensemble de
mesures de levier et nous avons besoin
d'une mobilisation dans les territoires
non seulement des élus parce que nous
savons que les élus sont mobilisés dans
les territoires mais en particulier des
administrations et des agences
territoriales de santé
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
dès que j'ai présenté le pacte réunit
l'ensemble des directeurs généraux des
agences régionales de santé pour leur
demander de ce mot ne se mobilise et de
faire en sorte que nous puissions
atteindre nos objectifs et donc le pack
qui se décline en trois axes qui
consiste d'abord à changer la formation
des jeunes médecins et les conditions de
leur installation à transformer les
conditions d'exercice et à investir dans
les territoires isolés alors je vais
très rapidement faut changer la
formation c'est favoriser les stages en
médecine et j'ai pris l'engagement que
100 % des étudiants pourraient devraient
réaliser un stage qui est d'ores et déjà
obligatoires mais qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui effectués j'ai indiqué que
d'ici 2017 1500 bourse de service public
serait accordée au cours des trois
dernières années 300 à peine l'ont été
et donc il y a là un volontarisme
assumer j'ai indiqué nous avions eu avec
en tout cas les les sénateurs qui se
sont eux qui se sont engagés dans la
discussion de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale évoquée g nous avons
voté donc la mise en place de 200 postes
de praticiens territoriaux de médecine
générale dès 2013
là encore il ne s'agit pas du tout comme
certains ont voulu dévoyer le système
oulalala mesure de créer un revenu
minimum avis il s'agit de sécuriser le
moment de l'installation des jeunes
médecins
parce que contrairement à ce que l'on
imagine s'installer dans un territoire
en particulier rural que l'on ne connaît
pas
suppose du temps pour se constituer sa
patientèle il y a aussi nécessité de se
faire connaître et donc on a besoin
d'engagement d'investissement et
d'investissement en matériel un jeune
médecin à des crédits à prendre enfin
pour ce qui est des études et de
l'installation g
indiqué pour faire face aux difficultés
que rencontrent les jeunes médecins
au moment de leur installation que
serait créée dans chaque région un
référent installation unique très
concrètement les agences régionales de
santé vont désigner partout dans nos
régions
une personne un bureau qui sera
identifié avec un comme je le dire non à
numéro de téléphone on saura qui on peut
appeler j'ai rencontré trop de d'un
terme lors de mes déplacements qui me
disait avoir voulu prendre des contacts
avec l' agence régionale de santé pour
avoir des informations et n'avoir pas
réussi à savoir où il était le plus
intéressant de s'installer quels étaient
les dispositifs dont il pouvait disposer
etc
ça c'est le premier axe donc qui
concerne les études et l'installation
des jeunes médecins
le deuxième axe est celui de la
transformation ou de l'accompagnement
des conditions d'exercice des
professionnels de santé puisque
aujourd'hui les jeunes professionnels
est d'ailleurs de plus en plus les moins
jeunes disent qu'ils ne souhaitent plus
travailler comme le faisaient leurs
prédécesseurs ils veulent travailler de
façon plus coordonnée en équipe
ils veulent des échanges et c'est la
raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle le
travail à l'hôpital apparaît comme un
peu là la référence nos jeunes médecins
sont formés à l'hôpital pour l'hôpital
et donc nous devons faire évoluer cela
nous allons donc valoriser le travail en
équipe en mettant en place des relais
rémunération forfaitaire d'equipe c'est
à dire que ce sont des rémunérations qui
n'iront pas au médecin individuellement
mais forfaitairement pour le travail de
coordination qui est réalisée dès lors
qu'il apporte un service supplémentaire
aux patients je prends deux exemples que
j'ai rencontrés très concrètement dans
mes déplacements
dès la constitution des équipes a permis
dans un certain nombre de cas
l'ouverture des cabinets médicaux sur
des plages horaires plus ample plus
large puisqu'il ya davantage de
professionnels donc là c'est un service
rendu nouveau à la population autre
exemple la constitution des équipes
permet de dégager du temps et de faire
apparaître des besoins nouveaux et c'est
un phénomène intéressant dans beaucoup
de maisons pluridisciplinaires de santé
qui fonctionne bien on voit s'installer
des diététiciens ou diététicienne je
dois dire plus souvent et qui viennent
répondre à un service et donc cela peut
ainsi être financée de manière nouvelle
l'autre élément je vous le disais c'est
de rapprocher l'hôpital de la maison en
fin d'exercice libéral et notamment de
considérer qu'on peut se former dans un
cabinet libéral que l'hôpital n'est pas
le seul lieu de formation pour la
médecine générale est donc avec
geneviève fioraso nous allons mettre en
place un label qui permettra de enfin la
belle universitaire qui permettra de
d'identifier les lieux les cabinets de
ville dans lesquelles il peut y avoir
une formation hors les murs j'ai pu par
exemple très concrètement voir l'intérêt
de ce type de dispositif
argenton sur creuse où je suis allé
inaugurer une maison santé tout à fait
exemplaire
nous allons également travailler au
développement de la télémédecine en
trait en faisant avancer les choses très
concrètement en prenant comme premier
exemple là où comme premier terrain
d'application la dermatologie à
télésurveillance en cardiologie
nous mettrons en place un programme
spécifique par ailleurs pour les
téléconsultations en ehpad
il faut avancer concrètement il faut
enfin si on veut modifier les modes
d'exercice des professionnels accélérer
les transferts de compétences on en
parle beaucoup on avance lentement et je
souhaite qu'une discussion puisse
s'engager avec les professionnels en
particulier avec les ophtalmologistes
pour voir puisque c'est un des secteurs
dans lesquels les temps d'attentes les
délais d'attentes pour avoir des
rendez-vous sont très importants voir
comment nous pouvons progresser
le troisième pilier du pacte territoire
santé ce sont ces années l'idée qu'il
nous faut investir directement dans des
territoires qui sont isolées cela
aboutira concrètement à mettre en place
les services du les moyens permettant à
des services d'urgence wade à l'accès
plutôt soins urgents de s'améliorer
puisque le président de la république
s'est engagé à ce que tous les
territoires soit axé sa est un accès à
des soins urgents en moins de 30 minutes
d'ici 2015 nous avons commencé dès
l'année dernière dès l'automne dernier à
déployer des équipements
nous allons permettre très concrètement
administrativement juridiquement à des
personnels hospitaliers ou salariés
d'aller travailler en appui en temps à
temps partiel par exemple dans les
cabinets libéraux c'est par exemple vous
avez une maison pluridisciplinaire de
santé ou pas une maison
pluridisciplinaire un pôle de santé vous
avez un médecin spécialiste hospitalier
qui pourra plus facilement que ça n'est
le cas aujourd'hui aller passer une
journée par semaine j'en ai tous les
quinze jours dans cette maison de santé
dans laquelle il y aura des rendez vous
qui seront pris et ça permet de déployer
et d'offrir des services davantage
réparties sur le territoire
nous allons par ailleurs réaffirmé
le rôle des hôpitaux de proximité et
responsabiliser les centres hospitaliers
régionaux à l'échelle de leur territoire
il y a
notamment l'idée que des professionnels
qui travaillent dans les chu ou dans les
chr pourrait aller davantage passer du
temps là encore non pas dans des
cabinets libéraux pour le coup mais dans
d'autres établissements hospitaliers des
petits établissements hospitaliers c'est
le statut d'assistant partager encore
faut-il que les chu lai ses médecins à
aller travailler dans des hôpitaux de
proximité
c'est notre volonté et puis il y à des
secteurs dans lesquels nous aurons
besoin de centres de santé salariés
j'ai lancé une mission de l'igas de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales et de l'inspection générale des
finances pour déterminer le modèle
économique où la manière d'adapter le
modèle économique de ces centres parce
que qui dit centre de santé doit dire
malgré tout efficience globale nous ne
pouvons pas avoir des structures qu'ils
soient durablement déficitaire voilà
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
manière dont nous avons engagé au
gouvernement le travail cela s'inscrira
de façon plus générale dans une
politique de santé redéfini à travers la
stratégie nationale de santé que le
premier ministre appelle de ses voeux et
dont nous aurons l'occasion de préciser
l'ensemble des contours très
prochainement nous avons évidemment
besoin pour réussir de la mobilisation
de tous je les dis je sais que les élus
sont très mobilisés et j'entends pour ma
part vous assurer de la mobilisation du
gouvernement et de toute
l'administration
merci madame la ministre pour s'imposer
très très précis donc donne toute la
parole à monsieur jean luc fichet oui
madame la ministre
d'abord merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous êtes effectivement en
face de la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
ce qui d'ailleurs
contrarie on pourrait dire un petit peu
la commission des affaires sociales qui
nous a vraiment donné mais comment se
fait-il que vous saisissiez de la
question des déserts médicaux est ce que
c'est pas d'autres problématiques à
notre commission des affaires sociales
donc on a réglé la question de leur
expliquant que notre approche était bien
une question d'aménagement de territoire
et c'était une réponse à des élus qui
aujourd'hui s'interrogent beaucoup sur
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir avoir comme offre
de soin sur leur territoire qu'ils
soient ruraux ou périurbain et je crois
que vous avez effectivement à travers
les deux propositions que vous venez
d'énumérer apporter déjà un bon nombre
de réponses qui sont sous la forme
incitative
alors certes n existait déjà mais on a
constaté que la communication c'était
mal fait tout l'intérêt était moindre
on peut les réactiver parce que c'est
vrai que par exemple contre un
engagement et sans doute une bonne
formule que de dire à des jeunes
médecins qui dispose de plus de moyens
pendant leurs études
écoutez si vous voulez vous vous engagez
pendant cinq ans les dans les
territoires sous dotées en échange de sa
pendant cinq ans on vous aide à financer
vos études et ça ma foi si c'est bien
communiquer je pense que ça devrait
créer de leur enthousiasme
donc il ya centre de dispositions comme
ça je vais pas énumérer mais qui sont
des bonnes qui sont des bonnes
dispositions moi je note avec beaucoup
de plaisir le fait qu' on va faire un
travail aussi sur les centres
hospitaliers de proximité dire que ça
c'est une demande qui est très
importante parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'inquiétudes autour des fermetures des
centres hospitaliers de proximité ou des
anciennes hôpitaux locaux ruraux des
assesseurs exemple on va tous rapatriés
dans la ville centre et puis ce qui ne
fait que de créer de l'éloignement et
donc ça c'est une
c'est une très bonne chose vous avez dit
effectivement que numéro deux us et
était suffisant et je crois que c'est ce
qu'on a pu entendre tout au cours de nos
auditions c'est pas nécessaire
d'augmenter du most aux us on a
suffisamment de médecins
maintenant à nous de les intéresser pour
la médecine générale et faire en sorte
que ils viennent dans les territoires
sous dotées moi je voudrais vous poser
une question parce que je crois que
c'est celle qui était la plus la plus
forte et qui sans doute et apparaîtra
dans notre rapport sert que la
coercition
au début j'étais je vais le dire
est favorable à cette idée au fur et à
mesure des auditions on s'est dit que ce
n'était peut-être pas la première
réponse qu'il fallait apporter mais par
contre on pense et on a entendu un
nombre de fois des propositions allant
dans le sens d'une régulation par le
conventionnement donc sérieux la chope
un conventionnement ça veut dire tout
simplement que si on considère qu'il ya
des territoires qui sont aujourd'hui
bien dotées en médecins qu'ils soient
médecins généralistes des médecins
spécialistes
si d'autres médecins veulent s'installer
dans des territoires qui sont déjà
suffisamment fournis il va à ce moment
là ils ne pourront plus bénéficier du
conventionnement et vouloir ne pourront
plus non plus prétendre aux aides
sociales ou aux avantages fiscaux dont
ils peuvent bénéficier
donc ça c'est des propositions qui sont
pas coercitive mais qui ressemble un
petit peu et il semblerait que ça ne va
sans doute pas répondre vous fait que
les médecins qui n'auraient pas de
conventionnement pour s'installer dans
des zones surdotées auront le réflexe de
dire je vais aller m'installer dans les
zones peu dotées sans doute pas dans ce
cas ça ça ça permettra de montrer qu' il
ya une volonté maintenant de réguler
d'installation et puis sans doute que
dans un second temps effectivement on
pourrait imaginer d'autres
l'accompagnement de ses médecins pour
qu'ils viennent dans des territoires a
priori qui les intéressent mois moi je
veux croire que la profession est
aujourd'hui très sensibilisé la question
des déserts médicaux certains supporter
m'a d'ailleurs l'expression des ans une
offre de soins qui n'est pas bien
équilibrée qui n'est pas bien ajustés
dans les territoires à nous de faire le
travail
donc ma question monsieur le président
pour que je fasse comme la question
c'est que pensez-vous de régulation prix
conventionnement merci je passe la
parole à monsieur hervé maurey si
monsieur le président et merci madame un
ministre d'être venu aujourd'hui dans le
cadre des travaux de ce
groupe de travail où nous tentons comme
l'a rappelé jean luc fichet de dégager
des solutions j'allais dire sans tabou
pour s'attaquer à ce véritable problème
des déserts médicaux qui est un problème
à la fois de santé publique mais aussi
d'égalité entre nos concitoyens santé
publique parce qu'on voit bien les
conséquences que ça sur certains
territoires et égalité parce que ce
n'est pas normal que dans certains cas
on soit en situation d'attendre 18 mois
un rendez-vous quand dans d'autres cas
on n'a même pas à attendre 18 jours
alors vous semblait effectivement avoir
pris conscience qu'il y avait un
problème et qu'il fallait tenter de le
régler
je suis assez d'accord avec vous sur le
fait qu'il n'ya sans doute pas de
solution unique et de solutions miracles
dans les dents les propositions que vous
avez rappelé je vais naturellement pas
les reprendre tout mais il me semble
qu'il y a à la fois des solutions qui
vont dans la bonne direction
c'est le cas de votre volonté qu'il y
ait un maximum 30 minutes de temps pour
accéder à des soins d'urgence
je me permettrai une parenthèse en vous
faisant remarquer qu'il n'ya pas que les
soins d'urgence
il y aller surtout cours et qu'en la
matière ce qui me paraît important ce
n'est pas la distance kilométrique
mais le temps d'attendre d'un rendez
vous et ça jusqu'à présent je trouve
qu'on en parle très peu dans la bonne
direction également le fait de vouloir
développer le travail en équipe de mener
une réflexion sur sur la rémunération
d'autres mesures ne semblent également
opportune mais pour l'instant j'allais
dire dans un champ d'application assez
restreint puisque soit télémédecine pour
l'instant ne l'expérimentent qu'en
matière de dermatologie le transfert de
compétences uniquement pour
l'ophtalmologie
le rapprochement maison de santé
université on se contente de recenser
les meilleures pratiques et puis le
président l'a dit lui même
d'autres
d'autres mesures existent déjà le fait
de dire qu'il faut que 100 % des
étudiants fassent leur stage en médecine
des étudiants en médecine générale face
leur stage en ville c'est déjà dans les
textes et vous nous dites pas comment
vous y arrivez les bourses d'engagement
de service public pareil ça existe déjà
vous voulez en faire d'autres très bien
mais le problème c'est que ça ne marche
pas parce que les étudiants ne veulent
pas alors vous nous dites pas c'est pas
en en rajoutant plus à mon avis que ça
que ça marchera davantage même chose sur
la possibilité de permettre à des
structures hospitalières d'apporter leur
soutien au monde ambulatoire c'est aussi
une disposition qui est dans la loi
bachelot et qui a du mal à fonctionner
justement parce qu'on a un aussi un
manque de médecins en hôpitaux donc là
aussi comment comment on fait en sorte
que ces mesures qui existent déjà
elle puisse fonctionner alors qu'elles
ont plutôt prouvez-le inverse et puis
dernière mesure à laquelle je ne crois
absolument pas
c'est la question des praticiens
territoriaux avec un revenu garanti
parce qu'on sait très bien que le
problème pour attirer les médecins en
zone rurale
c'est certainement pas la rémunération
puissent ils ont tellement de travail
que ceux qui viennent
ils ont largement la rémunération que
vous garantissez donc ça c'est
certainement une une mesure qui n'est
pas pertinente
en revanche il ya deux axes que vous
n'évoquez pas du tout j'en suis un peu
étonné la première c'est la formation
des futurs médecins
parce qu'aujourd'hui et ça aussi c'est
ressorti dans la cinquantaine
d'auditions qu'on a mené les futurs
médecins
ils sont uniquement tournés vers
l'hospitalier on nous disait pas plus
tard qu'au début d'après midi lors d'une
audition
aujourd'hui on forme pas des médecins en
forme des médecins hospitaliers et donc
il est clair qu'il faut une réflexion
sur l'enseignement et pas seulement par
rapport à a+ de sage mais sur les
matières qui ont ce qu'ils sont
enseignées on n'enseigne pas la gestion
n'enseigne pas la psychologie on
n'enseigne pas
la l'économie de la santé tout ça c'est
quelque chose qui est aussi totalement
absents de vos propositions et puis
dernier point pour ne pas être trop long
j'allais dire le point dur moi j'ai été
un peu étonné quand vous avez dit on
lance une concertation
on va regarder quelles soient les bonnes
mesures mais naturellement on ne
regardera même pas la question de la
coercition est ce qu on sait bien qu'en
france la coercition ses tabous et qu'un
gouvernement qu'ils soient de droite ou
de gauche il a tellement peur du lobby
médical
il y a des mots que l'on n'ose pas
utilisé alors je sais pas si pour vous
coercition et régulation tel que l'avait
évoqué jean luc fichet c'est la même
chose mais je crois qu'on pourrait
effectivement comme l'a dit jean luc
fichet au moins regarder cette piste là
parce que quand vous dites la coercition
c'est injuste faveur d'un ministre
d'accord mais est ce que c'est juste les
inégalités que l'on vit sur nos
territoires
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps de se
soucier vraiment de de l'intérêt général
et si c'est si injuste et si scandaleux
que ça alors il faut il faut être
cohérent il faut rendre la liberté
d'installation au pharmacien
il faut rendre la liberté d'installation
infirmières rendre la liberté
d'installation au kiné donc voilà je
suis dès demain porter un peu mais c'est
un sujet si vous voulez sur lequel nos
territoires ruraux vivent un tel drame
et parfois même des drames humains ce
qui est parfois des vies qui sont en
péril que j'aimerais vraiment sentir
qu'il ya une volonté de privilégier
avant tout l'intérêt général et pas
l'intérêt des médecins bien alors vous
souhaitez ces deux groupes de questions
qui sont déjà très fournie avant qu'on
passe aux autres madame disent peut-être
on peut peut-être laissé parler madame
la ministre elle a été questionnée donc
lui donne la parole
messieurs vous ferez insu de vos débats
en dehors madame la ministre vous avez
un merci monsieur le président je
voudrais je vais répondre aussi
précisément et en même temps rapidement
que possible à ces deux séries
d'interpellations du président et du
rapporteur de votre mission
je remercie jean luc fichet de dix ans
de son soutien à la démarche qui a été
engagée vous avez raison monsieur de
sénateurs de souligner que parmi les
mesures qui ont été avancées certaines
existent déjà
je veux indiquer que je crois fortement
qu'il y a enfin que si ces mesures n'ont
jusqu'à maintenant pas donné les
résultats attendus
c'est d'abord parce que prise isolément
elles ne peuvent pas aboutir
et donc je le dis le plan du
gouvernement réside autant dans le fait
de mettre en avant tout un ensemble de
dispositions que dans chacune des
dispositions prises séparément les unes
des autres même si séparément les unes
des autres elles peuvent répondre à des
problèmes particuliers mais l'enjeu est
bien de faire en sorte de jouer comme je
dédie sur tous les leviers existants et
le deuxième élément c'est la
mobilisation dans nos territoires
parce que moi j'ai été extrêmement
frapper encore une fois en rencontrant
les acteurs locaux les élus bien n'est
pas ça je l'entendais déjà auparavant
mais les jeunes médecins les étudiants
qu' il y à des dispositifs que vous moi
nous connaissons par coeur parce que
nous sommes d'abord vous voulez voter
nous les avons voté y compris dans le
passé et qui n'arrivent jamais à
destination ou a connaissance des gens
pour qui ils sont en théorie fait donc
il ya besoin
une mobilisation alors vous dites et je
salue aussi le fait que vous soulignez
que on a besoin de nos hôpitaux de
proximité moi je le dis les hôpitaux le
maillage territorial hospitalier est un
des facteurs contrairement à ce qu'on
peut imaginer de présence médicale
libéral ambulatoire dans nos territoires
alors est ce que on pourrait aller s'en
aller vers la coercition envers de la
régulation par le conventionnement
bon moi j'entends cela propositions que
vous faites vous avez raison de
souligner je crois que les jeunes
médecins n'y verrais pas beaucoup de
différence avec de la contrainte ou de
la coercition était la seule question
qui vaille c'est au fond est ce que
aujourd'hui ça aurait une chance de
fonctionner parce qu'on peut toujours
décider dire écoutez voilà une position
de principe et un m'adresse aux
rapporteurs la question de savoir si ça
peut fonctionner aujourd'hui nous sommes
face à un risque très précis pas pour
les médecins généralistes tellement mais
pour les médecins spécialistes nous
sommes face à un risque qui est celui de
la mise en place d'une médecine qui
serait non plus à deux vitesses mais
avec un fossé un gouffre entre une
médecine accessible et une médecine qui
ne le seraient plus des médecins pouvant
être tentés de se dé conventionnés moi
je le dis est allé dans la direction
d'une régulation par le
déconventionnement c'est s'exposer à ce
que des professionnels de santé au fond
assume de s'installer dans certains
territoires où ils considéreront qu'ils
auront une population solvable qui au
fond leur assureront des revenus
satisfaisants et ceux des conventions
euros on aurait à ce moment là le
résultat strictement inverse à celui que
nous recherchons et non seulement il y
aurait moins de professionnels
accessibles dans nos territoires mais en
plus nous aurions un divorce qui se
créerait au sein de la profession et au
sein de notre système de santé c'est la
raison pour laquelle je ne souhaite pas
nous ne souhaitons pas aujourd'hui
aller dans cette direction encore une
fois nous mettons en place une politique
nous ferons tout pour que cette
politique aboutissent à des résultats
parce que comme vous l'avait indiqué il
y à une prise de conscience de la part
des professionnels pas de tous je dois
dire des jeunes médecins pas de tous de
la nécessité au fonds de se préoccuper
aussi des conditions dans lesquelles
leurs futurs patients ou leurs patients
accède aux soins aujourd'hui je voudrais
dire à monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le sénateur hervé maurey qu' il ne m'a
pas bien entendu sur la formation des
médecins
j'ai même explicitement dit
qu'aujourd'hui les médecins étaient
formés à l'hôpital pour l'hôpital et que
c'était la raison pour laquelle nous
avions besoin d'aller vers la
labellisation universitaire de lieux de
formation extérieur à l'hôpital par
ailleurs nous avons engagées cela je ne
les ai pas évoquer j'ai souhaité
répondre à la demande de concision du
votre président j'ai nous avons engagé
la réévaluation de ce qu'on appelle la
maquette des études médicales puisque il
va y avoir il ya comme tous les dix ans
une remise à plat des contenus des
études médicales et nous allons voir
comment nous pouvons introduire des
enseignements qui vous parlais d'études
économiques sans gestion et c'est sans
doute peut-être nous avons aussi besoin
d'une part
d'une sensibilisation aux sciences
sociales qu'ils soient plus importantes
notamment quand on connaît les enjeux
éthiques auxquels sont confrontés les
professionnels mais nous avons aussi
besoin de mettre en avant tout ce qui
tient la médecine de parcours qui va
devenir décisives et qui va être au
coeur de notre stratégie nationale de
santé comment valoriser le travail en
équipe
comment mettre en avant ces éléments là
et nous sommes en discussion entre le
ministère de la santé ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche sur ces points là je pense que
j'ai entendu votre interpellation sur la
coercition je pense y avoir répondu par
ailleurs et j'avais eu l'occasion de
d'indiquer à l'assemblée nationale
lorsque la proposition de loi de votre
collègue monsieur vigier était venu en
débat les raisons pour lesquelles nous
n'y étions pas favorables condition que
les raisons que je et j'ai par ailleurs
rappelé et qui me semble aujourd'hui
toujours d'actualité merci alors je
voudrais préciser qu'il ya dix sénateurs
qui ont demandé à s'exprimer il nous
reste un quart d'heure donc que les
questions sur on sait tous que le sujet
passionnant et que vous le connaissez
tous mais poser la question pour qu'on
puisse avoir une pause si on n'y
arrivera pas la parole est à gérard
cornu oui madame la ministre
on peut tout s'entend sur le fait de
dire qu'il n'y a pas de mesure miracle
on est je pense tous d'accord là dessus
je voudrais reprendre très vite et très
synthétiquement une mesure que que vous
avez pris sur les praticiens
territoriaux je ne pense pas que ce soit
le problème du salaire qui est encore en
jeu je pense que c'est d'autre chose
lorsque les médecins hésitent à ce que
notamment dans l'eau ou dans le monde
rural
lorsqu'il est dit à s'installer c'est
qu'ils ont peur d'être seule vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure en fait il
ya une nouvelle approche de la médecine
et maintenant le médecin tout seul dans
un désert médical il
il a un peu peur et dont je ne pense pas
que ce soit une garantie de salaire est
en tout cas cette mesure
je vois pas trop comment elle va
fonctionner mais peut-être que vous
allez nous en dire un peu plus sur le
choix des départements sur la durée de
garantie deux salaires mais je voudrais
revenir sur autre chose dont vous avez
un peu parlé mais pas trop mais c'est
normal c'est le problème du transfert de
compétences je pense que la démographie
médicale est ce qu'elle est mais je
pense que on ne se sert pas à ces deux
professions qui ont fait des études
importantes
je pense aux pharmaciens aux opticiens
aux infirmières au kiné pour justement
réguler un petit peu les choses et que
le réflexe d'aller voir tout de suite le
médecin géré un généraliste
je pense que et pas forcément bon je
pense que ces professions ont la
capacité de réguler les choses
et lorsque ça dépasse leurs compétences
bien sûr d'envoyer et je crois que
c'était quelque chose à explorer nous
l'avons fait pour l'optique ici même au
sénat avec sur un texte consommation le
rapporteur était monsieur fauconnier et
constatant cette cette longue attente
des rendez-vous des ophtalmos nous avons
voté à l'unanimité ici au sénat la
possibilité pour les opticiens de
délivrer sur des ordonnances de moins de
cinq ans de porter de 3 ans à cinq ans
la durée de l'ordonance vous savez c'est
peut-être pas grand chose comme ça en
disant trois à cinq ans mais ça permet
de désemplir les rendez vous parce que
franchement l'attend au niveau des
ophtalmos très conséquente
et en plus ces professions pharmaciens
infirmières opticiens et kinés réguler
s'il ya une régulation dans le
territoire ils sont ils couvrent que
fortement le territoire et je pense que
ce transfert de compétence est à mon
avis un point essentiel pour réguler
cette désertification médicale
ainsi michel teston oui merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre
moi je voudrais évoquer la question de
la démographie médicale en psychiatrie
qui me paraissent se poser avec encore
plus d'acuité
que celle de la démographie 1-1 médecine
générale j'ai quelques éléments ici qui
doivent être malgré tout vérifier le
nombre de psychiatres a culminé en 2005
au dessus de 13000 et les projections
indiquent une diminution de plus de 40%
en 2020 quel que soit donc leurs
pratiques les psychiatres passe d'y
pratiquer soit public libéral ou
associatives se concentrent dans les
très grandes agglomérations il existe
donc d'immenses zones blanches en
psychiatrie l'âge moyen des psychiatres
et le plus élevé parmi tous les médecins
spécialistes
donc ma question est toute simple quelle
mesure en visée vous envisagez vous de
prendre pour renforcer la démographie
médicale en psychiatrie monsieur yves
rome avec le ministre j'ai noté avec
grande attention les évolutions que vous
souhaitez à apporter à ces grandes
difficultés que connaissent les
territoires et qui vivent très
cruellement cette fracture médical qui
est très presque équitablement réparties
sur tout le territoire national
j'ai noté avec beaucoup de plaisir que
les pistes évoquées
notre président les avait rejetés
peut-être un peu rapidement en tout cas
à terme elle me paraîtront devoir être
mise en oeuvre si on veut arriver à
obtenir une offre globale de soins sur
l'ensemble des territoires en
partenariat vous avez peut-être
insuffisamment soulignée avec les
territoires et les collectivités
territoriales qui seront des alliés
précieux pour pallier des gravement
qu'elle connaisse pour aboutir à
résoudre ces problèmes qui nécessiteront
en tout cas du temps et de la durée mais
je voudrais profiter de cette occasion
attirer votre attention sur des dégâts
collatéraux liés désertification
médicale de nos territoires qui
induisent des dépenses supplémentaires
pour les collectivités territoriales
je préside la commission nationale d
incendie et de secours des
sapeurs-pompiers 76% de l'activité des
sapeurs pompiers est lié
au secours à personne et c'est charge
incombe uniquement aux collectivités
territoriales j'aimerais que dans le
cadre de la réflexion sur les solutions
que vous devez apporter ce sujet fasse
l'objet d'un examen attentif
nous avons déjà sollicité l'inspection
des finances je vais très lié à 6 soit
associé pour que soit enfin réglé la
querelle entre les blancs et les rouges
et que soient mobilisés le secteur privé
ambulanciers qui profite très largement
du développement de son activité
lorsque le soleil brille et qui la nuit
très tranquillement dans les zones les
plus dangereuses parfois des quartiers
reculés de nouville décide de ne pas
intervenir
renvoyant au nom de la notion de troncs
secours vers les services départementaux
et d'incendié de secours l'obligation
d'intervenir ce sujet important pour les
territoires madame le ministre
et surtout pour les territoires sur
lesquels vous avez agi avant que de
devenir ministre
alors monsieur rémy pointereau oui
madame la ministre
merci de votre présence et de votre
présentation de de la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux la région centre que
vous connaissez bien et le deuxième du
désert médical de france après la
picardie notamment les spécialistes qui
font défaut dans les agglomérations de
notre région il ya un plan urgent
urgences santé qui s'est mise en place
au niveau de la région avec les maisons
de santé pluridisciplinaires qui vont
répondre à un certain nombre d'attentes
mais qui vont pas tout résoudre
c'est un c'est un point qui me paraît
quand même important de pouvoir le
mettre en place surtout dans le
département du cher qui est encore en
dessous des normes et des de la région
centre parce qu'on a un médecin pour
1000 habitants joie ou un peu plus il ya
sept ans d'engagement qui sont
intéressants les trois premiers mois je
n'y crois pas
le lestage les étudiants ne veulent pas
les bourses ça existe mais c'est pas
tellement publicité par les étudiants et
les praticiens territoriaux je ne suis
pas sûr que ça réponde enfin moi
j'attends par contre l'envasement news
numéro 9 me paraît tout à fait
intéressant parce que dans nos
territoires ruraux
ces vastes comme le cher par exemple on
évite très très vite
plus de 30 minutes de d'un accès aux
soins d'urgence notamment dans le sud du
cher et moi je souhaiterais qu'on parle
aussi d'urgences chirurgicales non
seulement d'urgence médicale mais
également chirurgicale
et je souhaite que cet engagement bien
se mettre en place très rapidement sur
le terrain avec un exemple concret que
nous venons de vivre dans le sud du cher
à saint-amand mon puisque la rs vient de
décider de fermer les urgences
chirurgicales les week-ends et jours
fériés et doivent ainsi aller les
habitants de l'année à bourges donc qui
est à plus d'une heure du sud du
département
donc je voulais savoir bon je crois que
c'est une provisoirement vous avez
stoppé sept pour six mois cette
opération
je souhaiterais savoir si vous allez
mettre en oeuvre vraiment de façon
efficace
cet engagement numéro 9 est que
définitivement ce genre de fermeture ne
revienne pas sur le tapis dans six mois
parce que je crois que ça crée je dois
le dire un choc véritablement dans le
département du cher parce que les
urgences de bourges sont déjà largement
saturé et je vois bien que bon vous
allez me dire que le schéma régional de
la rs s'applique pas ce que c'était une
décision avant votre
votre arrivée mais vous avez aujourd'hui
le pouvoir de changer des choses que
quand est il qu est ce que vous allez
faire pour ce genre de problème qui
risque de se passer dans d'autres
secteurs dans d'autres territoires
voilà mon inquiétude aujourd'hui ainsi
monsieur charles revêt oui merci à ce
président mam le ministre il se trouve
qu hier soir j'étais en réunion entente
plus notre communauté de communes avec
les médecins de mon secteur
réfléchissons à la mise en place d'une
et une maison médicale ou d'un pôle de
santé et 6e des médecins sont pas les
premiers acteurs avec nous ça ne
fonctionnera pas crois que c'est clair
donc mais j'avais six médecins qui
veulent s'investir et qui m'ont dit dans
trois ou quatre ans il y aura plus que
cinq médecins pour tout le secteur n'a
aucun avis 12 alors première il se
trouve qu'un d'entre eux avaient un
document et pour concernant les pôles de
santé je lui miarn n'est pas le lit lui
le le document mais à dix mais on va
nous faire faire encore une usine à gaz
pour monter un projet est-ce qu'on peut
simplifier au maximum parce que la
france est très diverse toutes les
situations sont pas comparables et je
crois que ce qu'il faut c'est bien sûr
répondent à des critères ça peut pas
être autrement
mais essayez des plus simples possibles
si on veut être efficace dans la mise en
oeuvre donc c'est ma première question
est ce que vraiment il ya il ya une
réglementation qui fait que avant
d'aboutir et c'est les ars que ceux qui
peuvent être en première ligne et qui
soit la plus simple possible pour mettre
en oeuvre et répondent aux besoins de la
population deuxième question qui va vers
les jeunes m'étais dit que les jeunes
étaient plutôt orientés vers les centres
hospitaliers et qu'après vingt ne
connaissons pas la réalité du terrain
ils sont pas incités à y aller or quand
les jeunes vont faire des stages y
compris d'un milieux ruraux ou dans des
milieux urbains va ce que vous avez eu
raison
wavre médecin me dit mais on était six
sondés +2 et bientôt et puis un vin de
médecins est ce que dans le cas du
parcours de formation il n'y avait pas
moyen d'inciter ou revoir dû faire une
obligation nous pour une partie des
stages que ce soit effectivement milieu
soit rural soit père urbam est un milieu
direct avec au côté bien sûr de médecins
qui accueille des stagiaires alors sur
laon rice oui madame un ministre merci
d'avoir bien mis l'accent sur bien sûr
les disparités que l'on connaît entre
les territoires urbains et les
territoires ruraux mais vous avez
également parlé des disparités à
l'intérieur des villes et je suis à un
élu d'une d'une grande ville et je
témoigne de cette petite ces disparités
avec un chiffre qui m'a complètement
frappé sur la question de l'obésité des
enfants à strasbourg dont je suis le
maire il y a un rapport de 1 à 4 ans
nombre d'enfants atteints d'obésité dans
les quartiers périphériques par rapport
aux quartiers centraux et je pense que
cela cela est lié évidemment des modes
de vie sort de leurs raisons mais aussi
à l'insuffisance de la présence médicale
et notamment des diététiciens ou
diététicienne dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure et on a nous mis en oeuvre une
politique de présence médicale à travers
des maisons médicales de santé dans les
quartiers on en a deux qui aujourd'hui
fonctionne est vraiment cela rend des
services énormes et les personnels sont
extrêmement motivés par
l'interdisciplinarité et les les
concitoyens dans les quartiers trouve
dans la même maison la possibilité de
s'adresser sans aller dans les
différents cabinets médicaux
ça me paraît très important j'ai cru
entendre tout à l'heure lorsque vous
avez dit que
c'est être un des éléments que vous
souhaitiez promouvoir j'ai pas très très
bien compris vous parler du financement
de l'interdisciplinarité si j'ai bien
compris à l'intérieur de ces de ces
pôles médicaux
si vous pouviez sur ce point précis me
donner une réponse parce qu'on a
d'autres projets de maison médicale de
santé à strasbourg
madame evelyne alors pendant je rends
sortie n'aime pas madame la ministre
merci pour avoir montré comme à quel
point votre gouvernement est mobilisé
sur la question de l'accès aux soins
quand on parle déserts médicaux on pense
souvent incapacité de se soigner et une
étape avant celle là c'est l'incapacité
à trouver un médecin référent dire que
je vis dans un territoire
alors il a été évoqué tout à l'heure par
à nos collègues qui a dit pire que nous
ya la picardie gt1 territoires dans
lesquels on ne trouve les patients ne
trouve plus de médecins référents cercle
animé cabinet ferme les médecins
arrêtent et quand et les médecins qui
sont toujours là ne veulent plus prendre
de patients en médecin référent ce qui a
des conséquences terribles parce qu'à un
moment donné les gens finissent quand
même par se faire soigner heureusement
notre pays a pas encore il ya cette voix
là ils sont passés aux urgences soit un
médecin qui n'est pas leur médecin
référent finit par les soigner sauf que
quand il s'agit de faire des analyses
médicales des examens médicaux les taux
de remboursement sont très faibles et je
me demande jusqu'à quel point
d'un certain point de vue c'est pas une
situation qui arrangerait les comptes de
la sécu que parce que je te trouve peu
offensif a essayé de résoudre ce
problème là qu'il faut résoudre parce
que c'est une vraie c'est une c'est la
double peine c'est la double peine pour
les les gens qui vivent dans les
territoires en difficulté mais ma
deuxième remarque porte europe mais en
bon je vais faire très vite mais ça
mériterait un débat plus long sur les
représentations que nous avons
concernant
les dianes le dialogue ou la difficulté
de dialogue avec les professions de
santé
je vois que mon collègue hervé maurey
pourtant pas connu pour son goût pour le
collectivisme et la foulée de la
fonctionnarisation émet des idées sur la
coercition mais avant la coercition je
me demande quand même s'il n'a pas la
citation je me souviens qu'à était paru
et quelques années une étude faite par
l'ordre des médecins qui révélait que
30% des études en médecine n'exerçait
pas à la fin des études de médecine et
la l'étude est pas très vieille a
peut-être changé un peu mais pas
beaucoup et en particulier les femmes
alors soit on a un point de vue sexistes
consiste à penser qu'elles font des
études de médecine pour se marier voilà
soit on regarde les choses un peu
autrement et on considère qu'aujourd'hui
les médecins veulent travailler sera
vite mais ce que je dis qu'en sautant de
commentaire soit soit on pense à soi on
admet on regarde les choses autrement et
on pense que les jeunes médecins
aujourd'hui veulent travailler en
structure collective est pas tout seul
et que hommes et femmes aspirent à un
défi qui ressemble un peu à la vie des
autres travailleurs c'est à dire que eux
aussi ont des enfants et se perd un peu
s'en occuper et le goût pour l'hôpital
et finement dû à la qualité de la
médecine qu'on exerce mais aussi au fait
de travailler en groupe et je me demande
un peu où sont passés tous les réseaux
de soins dont on a beaucoup parlé au
cours des dernières années on a mis en
place des réseaux de trains et puis d'un
coup de la présente aussi a disparu
je me rappelle des réseaux de soins en
matière de giné 20 prévention
je peux comme il s'appelait réseaux de
soins planification des naissances avec
une chaîne qui allait du médecin gynéco
et c'est autour d'eux des pilules daudet
des pilules du lendemain et que ce
n'était pas évident de malé ru486 voilà
autour du ru486 tout ça et on a
l'impression que toutes ces affaires de
réseaux qui nécessitent de l'argent qui
nécessite de l'investissement parce
qu'il faut payer le temps que les
médecins passent à travailler pour le
réseau se sont évaporés dans d'autres
priorités de santé et on a l'impression
quand même qu' il ya eu manque de
continuité de continuum dans
l'organisation de des soins dans
médecine en médecine de ville et moi
j'en pince pour ma part pour l'idée que
beaucoup de médecins sont intéressés
être être salarié beaucoup de jeunes
médecins voudraient bien être salarié et
que ça parle on a on n'a pas encore
trouvé à par l'hôpital
dans quelle structure on peut leur
apporter les murs une organisation de
soins qui leur permettent d'avoir un
cadre travail collectif les libérer de
tout ce qui est comptabilité etc
et c'est ça qui le demandent et notre
plutôt que la coercition
peut-être le salariat me paraît être une
bonne solution insuffisamment développée
et les médecins qui parle au nom des
généralistes sont toujours très attaché
aux modes de rémunération antérieure
pour ne pas dire arcade
merci alors jacques qu'on a nous
alors je vous fais tout saluer madame la
ministre des affaires sociales de la
santé
je voudrais simplement profité pour
vraiment vous sensibiliser la drogue
attention parce que la couverture
sanitaire en guadeloupe d'une manière
générale et notamment à marie galante
pose problème et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs j'ai organisé à la demande
des élus de l'île
une rencontre avec l'ensemble des élus
et la dieccte elle à dire que de la rs
et particulièrement se joue l'âge nous
avons noté la détresse
j'insiste là dessus la détresse
psychologique du personnel et des
malades puisque l'hôpital a été fermé
sans information et la situation est
grave c'est pourquoi je vous ai alerté
de manière à vous rencontrer jeudi
personnellement pas la directrice de la
rs avec d'autres élus parce que cette
couverture sanitaire
c'est un problème crucial depuis des
années pas vous 1
les prédécesseurs du temps de la droite
nous avons alerté tout le monde les
pouvoirs publics ont du mal à résoudre
parce que l'accès aux soins et je vous
l'avez vous l'avez bien précisé est à
plus de 30 minutes
un hélicoptère qui est souvent basée à
martinique ou à pointe à pitre
d'autrefois étaient en panne il y a eu
plusieurs cas semblables à la corrèze et
le cas qui s'est produit en corrèze très
rapidement le président a intervenu mais
il ya des dizaines de cas tous les jours
et très souvent ne le dis pas pour
faciliter la tâche pour ne pas faire
tâche d'huile
les malades prennent le bateau le temps
du voyage est de 45 des tuners qu'à la
mer n'est pas démonté alors je voudrais
vraiment
depuis ce n'est pas ce n'est pas là je
vais tout développer mais vous
sensibilisez là dessus et précisé qu au
regard des engagements pris par le
président de la république je l'avais
sensibiliser avant les lorsqu'il était
passé pour préparer les élections
il avait précisé clairement dans les 30
engagements disant que je vais renouer
avec l'excellence de notre système de
santé il renforcer l'hôpital public
contre mr voilà pour l'essentiel de
l'audition de marisol touraine par le
groupe de travail sénatorial sur la
présence médicale sur le territoire
français bon après midi à tous